en ce moment c'est difficile de prévoir
quels seront les impacts économiques du
coronavirus et si ça aura un effet sur
l'immobilier
mais pour ceux qui cherchent un
appartement loué ou acheté un condo une
maison il ya de quoi être découragés par
les prix toutes sections ses études et
qu'on divise depuis de l'a14 ici
énormément de rénovation éviction
locataires à montréal maison
complètement hors de prix à vancouver
comme deux millions de dollars pour
celle ci les prix grimpent en flèche et
les raisons sont parfois surprenants
attendez de voir l'expérience en caméra
cachée qu'on a monté et qui démontre la
facilité de blanchir de l'argent dans
l'immobilier à montréal ouais je veux
jouer que veut y étaient compris qu on
en revient de dates au chanteur mis
devant l'argent sale
vous allez voir la réaction des
courtiers immobiliers ça vienne de
n'importe quoi on se sait pas moins jugé
qu la commission voie de gauche puis la
morale aux bahamas et elle estime que 6
rebonds problème avec ça
ici marie maude denis bienvenue à
enquêtes spéciales immobilier montréal
n'est plus en reste des grandes villes
du monde
elle est touchée à son tour par la
frénésie de l'immobilier depuis janvier
le prix des immeubles augmente quatre
fois plus vite que le coût de la vie a
été un trimestre de hausse de suite dans
le marché résidentiel de montréal est ce
qu'on a déjà vu ça mais une enquête
révèle à quel point cette opportunité en
or pour les investisseurs deux plaques
c'est complètement fou c'est la folie
des offres multi est devenu un cauchemar
s'ils se sont toutes vides et ici pour
les locataires qui en subissent le
contrecoup
ça va être une prochains acheteurs qui
va arriver puis qui va décider de sortir
tout le monde parce que finalement il
peut faire un peu d'argent
le logement est un droit de plus en plus
menacé c'est que le logement est traitée
comme une marchandise ou il ya pas
d'humains à l'intérieur c'est juste un
objet de spéculation
[Musique]
propriétaire prêteurs courtiers ils
étaient plus de 800 réunis récemment à
montréal
attirés par les promesses exceptionnelle
de l'immobilier tout y est pour doper le
marché une économie robuste une poussée
migratoire et une pénurie de logements
qui frôle la crise
l'effervescence touche au temps des
grandes tours d'habitation la
construction de neuf que les plex qui
font le caractère si particulier de
montréal toute cette section le site web
de conduite
le puits de la capeb ici énormément de
reno vision c'est fou ce team ub leur
immeuble de six logements est mis tout
le monde dehors transformées en condos
indiqué martin blanchard est en première
ligne ou comité logement de la
petite-patrie
le logement est d'abord un chez soi le
locataire paie un loyer convenable
propriétaire fournit un service adéquat
on n'est pas là dedans le quand on parle
de marchandisation et de
financiarisation on est faut faire de
l'argent le plus vite possible
alarmé par la hausse des plaintes qui
ont triplé en deux ans le comité
logement a décidé d'enquêter des cas de
reprise et d'éviction
c'était laborieux en termes de travail
en termes de ressources jamin le 14
montréal est une exception au canada
avec près de la moitié de ménages
locataires
ce sont eux qui paient le prix de
l'engouement pour l'immobilier
selon louise gaudreault professeur à
l'uqam les gens qui achètent dans le
marché à la hausse
sand est plus que jamais et sont
entraînés dans une spirale la pression
qui s'exerce heureux pour rembourser
leur prêt hypothécaire
il me contrait à se tourner vers leurs
locataires pour soit augmenter les
loyers ou soit essayer de les remplacer
par des gens qui pourraient payer plus
cher le droit de propriété de pouvoir
rénover son immeuble
la corporation des propriétaires
immobiliers trouve que ce sont les
loyers qui ne montrent pas assez vite
pour absorber les coûts de rénovation
les le parc immobilier locatif leur a
été construit surtout dans les années 50
60 des rénovations majeures doivent sont
nécessaires pour relouer des locataires
dans certains cas plus cher c'est vrai
mais est ce qu'on les mieux climat donc
qu'on reconstruise des cours d'eau mais
il y à des propriétaires il y à des
spéculateurs des gens qui sont là de
façon très assumé pour l'argent les des
spéculateurs qui font un qui achètent
dans le but de transformer rapidement
puis de revendre rapidement à tout prix
mélinda a porté plainte contre son
propriétaire à la régie du logement
elle habite rue bélanger ça fait des
mois qu'elle est forcé de laver sa
vaisselle dans sa baignoire alors fait
c'est que ça se passe c'est l'heure la
pièce multifonctions salle de bains
espace de nettoyage vaisselle lithium le
problème vient de la plomberie de sa
cuisine
j'étais en train de force de lavage
plaît tout d'un coup ça s'est mis à
gicler en dehors du tuyau lol l'avare
offert en plus évident est le
propriétaire lui a demandé de partir
mais melinda vit avec son fils à
quelques pas de l'école qu'ils
fréquentent à 900 dollars
son logement est un des rares encore
abordables dans le quartier la loi lui
permet de rester alors ils exigent que
la plomberie soit réparé glisser dans ma
porte je reçois une réponse à ma mise en
demeure qui dit que que j'ai pas le
droit de toucher à rien puis en plus
j'ai une éviction qui dit qu'il faut que
je parte parce qu'il veut subdiviser le
logement
le propriétaire dit maintenant vouloir
transformer les six logements neufs le
jugement
julie qui habite l'étagé du dessous
depuis plus de dix ans est sous le choc
mais on est surpris fâché démunis on a
beaucoup beaucoup de questions dans ce
sens où est ce que j'ai vraiment pas
choix est ce qui est vraiment un endroit
où je m'envole d'autres quartiers
rapporte la même hausse marquée de
locataires qui craignent de se faire
évincer sous de faux prétextes d un
phénomène en pleine explosion dans les
quartiers comme le plateau mont royal un
sud-ouest de montréal où les thons
d'inoccupation front à peu près les 0%
en ce moment donc il ya un contexte qui
favorise ces pressions que vivent les
locataires plusieurs quartiers voit
l'apparition croissante d'un autre type
de propriétaire georgette rébillon vie
au centre ville depuis trente ans son
immeuble a été acquis en 2015 par 4,8 un
des plus grands fonds de placement
immobilier au canada et depuis elle se
bat pour faire respecter ses droits
je n'ai jamais eu de problèmes de
chauffage depuis qu'ils sont arrivés ça
chauffe plus parce que vous allez vous
plaindre on bat la réponse est on n'y
peut rien c'est toronto qui gère le
chauffage à toronto comme à montréal des
locataires se sont plaints de problèmes
semblables dans d'autres immeubles de
4,8
madame rébillon a vraiment l'impression
que le propriétaire réduit les dépenses
le plus possible c'est pas difficile
ils ont tous supprimés ils ont supprimé
le une scène qui faisait le ménage
finement une fois par semaine ils ont
supprimé le peintre et ils ont supprimé
le guardian
cap read a enregistré une performance
record en 2019
les appartements ça rapporte comme
l'entreprise se plaît à le dire dans des
rapports à ses actionnaires
la fonction d'un fonds de vis d'un fonds
de placement immobilier d'un ruitz et de
générer de la route pour des
actionnaires c'est des gestionnaires des
gestionnaires qui ont pour principale
tâche de justement le mental d'augmenter
la valeur du portefeuille
montréal est maintenant dans la mire de
plusieurs grands fonds de placement
immobilier
ils ont effectué plusieurs milliards de
dollars d'acquisitions dans la métropole
ces deux dernières années dans les
quartiers comme la petite patrie la
spéculation immobilière prendre d'autres
formes
l'anc est mené par le comité logement
révèle que le phénomène des rénovations
et des démos fiction où poussent les
locataires à la porte a pris une ampleur
qui dépasse tout ce qu'il imaginait nos
conclusions de nos enquêtes sur 4 ha
de travail sur 362 unités
c'est que 80 5% de ses 362 unités de
logements ont fait l'objet d'une fraude
ou d'une malveillance
on n'en revient pas de l'ampleur c'est
que ce soit systématique dans 22% des
cas on se serait débarrassé des
locataires sous de faux prétextes pour
relouer plus cher ou vendre 62% des cas
serait de la malveillance
la tentative d'éviction de reprise
auraient échoué mais les locataires sont
partis à force d'usure ce qui fait dire
à martin blanchard que si la loi est si
souvent contourné ce qu'il est facile de
le faire
en fait cette invitation à la fraude
la manière dont les lois sont faites
dont le droit est appliquée c'est un
aveuglement complet à toutes les fraudes
et la malveillance que l'on voit en
matière de logements qui sont utilisés
pour la spéculation
l'intérêt qu'on porte en ce moment au
marché immobilier tout l'optimisme qu'on
a quand à la halle à 11 h p des valeurs
et cetera les prix fait en sorte qu' il
ya de plus en plus d'incitatifs de
contourner les règles en place
la transformation d'appartements en
condos les locations court terme de type
airbnb et les flip très populaire aura
en plus on va faire un flop sont des
opportunités d'affaires qui répondent
souvent à la même logique spéculative
mais qui aggrave la pénurie de logements
rue bélanger la plomberie 2001 est
bouché depuis trois mois on a
l'impression en fait que le le
propriétaire utilise ne fait que la
plomberie est défaillante pour me
pousser en dehors de mon logement
mélinda a finalement déposé une plainte
pour insalubrité auprès de la ville de
montréal
la plomberie a été réparée en 24 heures
quatre des six ménages de son immeuble
contestent leur éviction devant la régie
du logement
on est allé contesté à la région
selon alain kan doute que le
propriétaire veut vraiment faire ces
travaux là convoqué devant la régie le
propriétaire était incapable de produire
les informations requises pour justifier
son projet il n'a pas retourné nos
messages les locataires attendent
toujours le jugement
pour la première fois de sa vie madame
rébillon s'est aussi tournée vers la
régie pour contester une hausse de loyer
de 4 et demi pour saint exigées par le
fonds de placement 4,8
j'ai dit que j'étais trop mais vous
savez c'est un compagnie avec des des
investisseurs dont ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] de moi rire du tout
l'entreprise dit avoir investi 3
millions de dollars dans l'immeuble
depuis son acquisition pour expliquer
cette hausse
la régie l'a finalement réduite de plus
de la moitié
la régie du logement ignore combien
david deux reprises et d'éviction sont
émis chaque année elle ignore aussi
combien s'avère justifiée quand on dit
que c'est une invitation à la fraude
c'est ça c'est que lui rien qu'ils
vérifient aucune vigilance
le taux élevé de présumées fraudes et de
malveillance mis au jour par l' enquête
du comité logement de la petite-patrie
signale un problème important avec un
marché en pleine ébullition
rien n'indique qu'ils soient sur le
point de se résorber
au retour notre opération en caméra
cachée notre infiltrateur veut recycler
son argent sale dans l'immobilier ce que
ça va fonctionner la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
l'immobilier c'est un moyen pour les
criminels de recycler de l'argent sale
c'est pour ça que les courtiers
immobiliers sont obligés de déclarer les
transactions suspectes
or le taux de dénonciation est
ridiculement bas alors on a voulu savoir
comment réagir et des courtiers
immobiliers en présence de blanchisseurs
d'argent
vous allez voir que les mailles du filet
sont grandes ouvertes
[Musique]
comment puis je vous appelle pour un de
nos clients et vous nous sommes son
gestionnaire de patrimoine
il arrive lundi de panama et mardi ils
aimeraient bien en proposent ces visites
est d'après vous convenir oui cover se
préparer
lui c'est damian un employé fictif d'une
compagnie tout aussi fictive optimise
management qui gère la fortune de riches
clients à partir de new york fut
amateurs mais fait pour ça et on a beau
soleil
en réalité il n'est pas à new york
il téléphone de radio canada damian et
un de nos collaborateurs
il appelle des agences immobilières pour
planifier des visites avec des courtiers
il dit que c'est pour son client qui vit
à l'étranger et qui souhaitent acquérir
une résidence à montréal je rencontre
est qu'elle perfore là vous allez
rencontrer monsieur bernard bernard
wheaton bernard hayot première tonne
bernard
[Musique]
son client tonne bernard n'existe pas
non plus c'est un autre de nos
collaborateurs qui joue ce rôle où est
envoyé se faire avec sa facture à dalian
depuis comme un homme dans la
soixantaine va visiter des propriétés
avec mélissa sa jeune copine dans la
vingtaine c'est notre troisième
collaboratrice elle jouera une étudiante
à l'université mcgill acquis tom veut
acheter un condo d'au moins un million
de dollars mais ce n'est pas le plus
surprenant de l'histoire de tom pour ça
que ou alors j'en viens du stupéfiant
sauf que là c'est que tu as de l'argent
qui restait caché au panama toi tu dis
la police a jamais réussi à trouver
l'argent n'est jamais moi j'existe on
sait elle que pour les blazers c'est
tout ce qui est en contravention avec le
code kill bill est elle si simple si je
commets un équilibre c'est de l'argent
si domination j'essaie de blessés john
powell et au cours des prochains jours
tom magazine rats avec son argent sale
de luxueuses propriétés des condos et
des maisons de rêve
nous avons choisi cinq courtiers
immobiliers au hasard comment vont-ils
réagir
[Musique]
mardi 18 février tom et mélissa kit
radio canada ils sont accompagnés par
notre réalisateur qui sera passée pour
un adjoint
tous portent sur eux et caméras cachées
notre scénario va se jouer sur les trois
prochains jours
[Musique]
ils n'iront pas voir des propriétés
accessible au commun des mortels
l'agent new yorkais leur a organisé des
visites dans cinq propriétés de prestige
tout plus cher les unes que les autres
ils iront dans des tours du centre ville
dans le vieux-montréal et jusque dans
les hauteurs de wesmount
on s'étonne enchanté comme ça va bien
aller faire un tour
c'est aujourd'hui dans certains
appartements
la vue est à couper le souffle ailleurs
les intérieurs son fastueux l'euro et
des courtiers ne se limite pas à mousser
les charmes des propriétés ils ont aussi
l'obligation légale de dénoncer les
opérations de blanchiment d'argent et
même les tentatives d'opérations
douteuses
c'est exactement ce que tom s'apprête à
tester tous capables les jours ce qu'il
va dire aux courtiers ne laisse aucun
doute quant à la provenance de l'argent
qu'il fait miroiter de moi c'était des
années dans d'accord ok j'ai fait
beaucoup d'argent avec la colombie
voici on suit les années 90 j'ai eu un
vrai danger juste fier
ronald et j'ai accumulé beaucoup
d'argent qui est placé à l'extérieur
canadien bien sûr ok tu étais un thé %
je croyais 700 ans
j'ai réduit mes affaires mon argent
provient de
elle est placée à la mort mba obame aux
voix ce qu'un je recherche la
confidentialité une déclaration sans
ambiguïté qui laisse une courtière sur
ses gardes
le marché sur l'eau oui bien sûr mais je
travaille comme vendeur si vous voulez
vraiment confidentialité mais pour les
quatre autres
ça ne semble pas être un obstacle bien
au contraire même si mon argent est
placé il ya bien deux l'avant du super
classe et d'algérie à l'hôtel the pays
moi ça vienne de n'importe quoi on se
sait pas moins du juste ok mais mon
argent provient d'autres certains ça me
dérange pas du tout mon meilleur ami
c'est mon héros ni son mari c'est la
même chose le même situation donc je
suis pas là pour juger je peux là pour
culpabiliser c'est chacun paie sa vie
chacun service et donc je vous entends
moi je m'assurerai que j ai bien compris
que dumont a rien de bien de dado
passante un panama j'en ai fait
monsieur m'a plu c'est beaucoup a
grandement plaisir de jeu nioche à la
neige et mieux la voir nous avons montré
ces images à des experts le scénario
crédible
la force de votre scénario c'est
justement son caractère qui parfois
farfelus comme comment ces gens alors
ont pu mordre et être si confortable
devant quelque chose d'aussi sans
ambiguïté sans ambiguïté saison s'est
dessiné au crayon gros lot
[Musique]
la provocation était clair et le hipster
blanche ça pour cette éthiciens qui
enseigne aux courtiers immobiliers
ceci devrait dénoncer un tel cas aux
autorités quand le client musique est
très fière drogue ou à peu près
ben ali et règlements disent qu'il faut
le dit le site de la shdm et si la
transaction avait procédé il aurait pu
faire face à des accusations criminelles
le fait d'avoir caché sur c'est passible
de prison
bonjour je m'appelle julie dufresne je
suis journaliste à radio canada pour
l'émission enquête nous préparons un
reportage sur le blanchiment d'argent
dans l'immobilier
une semaine après une autre opération
nous contactons les courtiers pour leur
demander ceci je me demandais est-ce que
vous avez personnellement été témoin de
ce genre de situation la géorgie pas
gros expérience du prophète du centre
action donc j'ai moi j'ai jamais vu ça
de mon côté je n'avais jamais eu de
clients qui vous a proposé de faire ce
type de transaction la non non des
blanchiments d'argent ou rien du genre
non non sur les cinq courtiers quatre
ont affirmé ne pas avoir été témoin de
tentatives récentes de blanchiment
d'argent
nous le révélons donc la vérité au sujet
de ton bernard j'aimerais vous demander
dernier
oui je raconterai m'insultant bernard
d'accord je dois vous informer que ton
bernard un personnage fictif que les
missions locales procréer au moment de
notre appel
aucun courty n'avait déclaré de
tentative de transaction douteuse
confrontés à leur réaction lors de nos
visites
tous se sont vivement défendu d'avoir
manqué à leurs obligations légales
[Musique]
y a rien du tout il elle lorsque j'ai dû
lui la vie j'ai payé mes dettes
j'ai fait tout ce que tout mon temps oui
j ai fait dans les années 90 mais qui
sont moins bons en tant qu'outil
immobilier g je veux qu'on s'habitue
envers mon vendeur puis je dois flag et
le monde sain blanchiment d'argent mais
selon moi une fois qu'il ya une offre
déposée chez là où j'aurais dû le
flaguais nous avons également montré nos
images à l'organisme
d'autoréglementation du courtage
immobilier du québec
l'oas et i q de façon générale est-ce
que ce que vous avez vu la correspondent
à des comportements que vous espérez
world de courtiers immobiliers mais
évidemment que non évidemment que c'est
extrêmement préoccupant que c'est
extrêmement troublant qu'elle entendre
des situations comme celle-là mais est
ce que c'est vrai que il doit prioriser
la vente pour son vendeur sans se
préoccuper par exemple potentiel
blanchiment d'argent ou un potentiel
manquement à ses obligations légales
la réponse est simple c'est non non il
doit vraiment s assurer du respect des
de toutes ses obligations autant à
l'égard du fondeur que de l'acheter plus
la commission white gauche puis laborde
à l'avancé et élastique
si jed maison m 3 pour ça mais aussi
billions de là ça donne si j'ai oublié
qu'ils puissent 150 mille dollars de
commissions se peut peut-être avoir une
marraine plus élastique
[Musique]
ne manquez pas au retour la suite de
notre enquête
[Musique]
de retour à nos visites en caméra cachée
nous avons vu la réaction initiale des
courtiers quand notre client propose
d'acheter avec de l'argent qui provient
de la drogue
notre sulfureux personnage ne s'arrête
pas là où cinq courtiers il annonce
aussi qu'il veut cacher son identité et
que son nom n'apparaisse nulle part dans
la transaction
c'est mélissa qui signera pour acheter
la propriété au nom d'une compagnie les
états nations unies d'avoir des clac
je dois identifier le tiers s'est levé
les acheteurs
parce que tous les libyens vont voulait
se cacher alors je veux savoir qui avait
cet argent le danger d'un soutien pour
moi c'est ce que je veux non des papiers
dette en europe
parfait ok ça c'est la rsp de la marimba
documents et bien coexister penser ça
comme si on s'était jamais vu je me
demandais des pièces d'identité vous de
venir au csu s'éclate man à fond si vous
n'êtes pas l'acheter non à mes yeux nous
attachons donc mais c'est mélanger rien
de ces matières animé par semaine les
documents qu'a rester quoi que ce soit
pas reconduit
que ce soit mon agence et tous nos
rapports hockey ni maintenant ni plus
tard ni jamais un or maintenant que
madame c'est madame qui est moi je gagne
l'argent souvent inquiètes sur votre
pays j'espère que vous publiez vous vous
êtes bien avec le fait que mon nom
l'appareil sert aux problèmes avec sa
jument zéro preuve il faut bien que ce
soit sur le long de quelque chose pour
les compagnies ont quand même temps une
compagnie ou médecin j'ai zéro problème
avec ça j'adore votre fait
et si c'était vos élèves ses courtiers
est-ce qu'ils passaient leurs cours dont
un acceptant de poésie danse fils tiers
belle c'est qu'ils acceptent d'être en
contravention avec
les règlements les courtiers sont des
facilitateurs de transactions les choses
pourraient pas se faire de cette façon
alors si multitude de professionnels ne
faisait pas de l'aveuglément volontaire
la juste la compagnie
et si les courtiers ferme les yeux il
peut être par la suite difficile voire
impossible de savoir qui se cache
derrière une transaction dans l'eiffel
qui mauvais risques dans quatre murs
exactement ça
et si les pigeons bien failli coûter les
blanchisseurs font fortune à vancouver à
toronto
ça commence à bord et un pays utilise
était claire decaux pays qui est des
prêts dont fort de données probantes
on peut pas déterminer l'ampleur le rôle
exact joué par le blanchiment d'argent
dans la spéculation immobilière à
montréal c'est certain que le
blanchiment d'argent est un facteur qui
justifie la hausse des prix à l'heure
actuelle et vous le voyez très bien
nous décidons de pousser l'exercice plus
loin nous demandons une deuxième visite
aux courtiers monsieur bernard est
intéressé par votre propriété est ce que
c'est possible
et puis pour voir plan a bien sûr place
ce qu'on s'attendrait d'un scénario
comme ça c'est déjà refusé une deuxième
rencontre on peut toujours justifié la
politesse la première rencontre par le
fait que c'est c'est pas des policiers
de carrière savent pas comment réagir et
des criminels qui ont une certaine forme
de courtoisie naturel peut-être tous
acceptent de le recevoir à nouveau tome
laisse miroiter qu'il est prêt à faire
une offre d'achat confiance aux yeux
puisque pour moi et pour vous c'est moi
que je connais ce que je veux c'est un
contre de hushovd à chose pour payer
avec un chèque qui vient des compagnies
air tahiti mis par la compagnie
autorisée par moody's
bush à se joindre à nous on va remplir
le formulaire qu'on le soit appliquée
même celle qui semblait douter accepte
une nouvelle rencontre
elle en remet une proposition d'offre
d'achat qu'elle a en partie remplie
[Musique]
mais lorsqu'on accepte une deuxième
rencontre puis on arrive avec des
documents pour faire une offre d'achat
en expliquant de quelle façon le nom de
notre monsieur n'apparaître rapport là
je pense que ça démontre un niveau de
confort de normalisation de ces crimes
blocs sont troublants mélissa n'est plus
présente lors de cette deuxième visite
où on discute d'une offre d'achat
qu'elle doit pourtant signé sont tous
les courtiers accepte d'authentifier
l'identité de mélissa à l'aide d'une
simple photocopie
ça c'est clair que cet encours de
réversion avec la loi on doit voir les
originaux des pièces à la pointe
photocopies une photocopie on peut faire
n'importe quoi avec une photocopie
par contre et même si ça peut paraître
étonnant la loi permet aux courtiers de
procéder à la transaction est de faire
la déclaration d'opérations douteuses
ensuite certains d'entre nous ont dit
que c'est ce qu'ils auraient fait c'est
la transaction avait été plus loin
à partir du moment où est-ce qu'on a un
soupçon qu'on a un doute on doit le
déclarer
1 c'est la clé c'est c'est le partage
d'informations si on partage
d'informations alors là on agit en un
mot et les courtiers peuvent agir comme
chien de garde à ce niveau là pour
empêcher justement qu'il y ait
blanchiment d'argent
il faut se demander avec quelle
efficacité et les courtiers aurait pu
aider les autorités à identifier nos
blanchisseurs après coup ils n'ont
aucune pièce d'identité pour tom et une
photocopie facilement falsifiable pour
mélissa ils ont les obligations de faire
les vérifications d'identité
alors si ce qu'il devait faire et c'est
ce qu'ils ont passée semble qu'il n'ait
pas fait ça au moment où est ce que les
questions leur ont été posées
[Musique]
dans la propriété la plus chère celle à
près de 7 millions un courtier senior
accompagne sa collègue moins
expérimentés c'est lui qui prend le
relais et poursuit les discussions on
voit s'affronter deux noms qui vous
convient j'ai essayé de nous et on est
extrêmement de rénover les choses selon
les règles de l'art avec 3,6 kg mais on
n'est pas le coup il ne questionne
jamais ni l'identité ni les intentions
de tom bernard nous avons contacté ce
courty douteux à passe en ce moment où
est-ce qu'on a un soupçon des indices
que des drapeaux rouges qui se lève on
doit le déclarer ses seules obligations
du courtier il affirme que sa collègue
ne lui avait jamais dit que l'argent
provenait du trafic de drogue
plutôt que de mettre un terme à la
transaction vous avez accepté une
deuxième visite à laquelle vous avez
participé y avait pas l'air d'avoir
aucun problème à procéder à la
transaction plus furieux le jeu le plus
honnête mais pour lou asei q cette
deuxième visite n'aurait carrément
jamais dû avoir lieu par la mesure où
est ce qu ils sont dans une situation où
est ce que il constate qu il ne prend on
pas remplir leurs obligations
déontologiques et bien ce moment
effectivement elle devrait dénoncer la
situation puisse retirer aussi clair que
ça
c'est vraiment bon
[Musique]
ses courtiers seront les premiers à nous
faire parvenir une ébauche d'offre
d'achat par courriel au total nous avons
reçu trois offres d'achat venues une
réalité sur certains dénoncent depuis
longtemps
donc oui c'est un wake up call c'est un
wake up call qui doit être pris très
sérieusement par les premiers ministres
des provinces canadiennes
il faut comprendre que le seul outil
couvrait les lumières sur une forme de
criminalité comme le blanchiment
d'argent
c'est une commission dans lequel parlant
d' enquête publique après la pause on va
à vancouver où se tient justement une
enquête publique sur le blanchiment
d'argent dans l'immobilier
ça va nous donner une idée de ce qui
nous attend peut-être si rien ne change
[Musique]
sur la côte ouest les tours de condos se
multiplient et les prix des mobiliers
atteindre la stratosphère
le rêve d'accès à la propriété devient
de plus en plus illusoire pour la classe
moyenne
bienvenue à vancouver où le marché
immobilier est devenu une cible du crime
organisé
[Musique]
écoute je ne sais pas combien une offre
mais c'était plusieurs
j'ai même pas encore à combien ça s'est
vendu mais c'était au dessus s'est vendu
aux côtes sud et puis c'était déjà 1
point 3 l'ingénieur québécois françois
vitesse et sa compagne marjolaine savoie
se cherche une nouvelle demeure mais
même pour des professionnels
vancouver est devenu presque hors de
prix françois vitesse visite des condos
et des duplex en banlieue de vancouver
il m'a pas les moyens d'acheter une
maison unifamiliale ce qu'on dit est
offert à 998 1000 $ pour les enfants
aussi je vois pas comment ça peut
arrêter de monter où je vois pas comment
ça peut descendre
moi ce qui me préoccupe le plus c'est
mes enfants je peux pas m'imaginer une
profession légale qui peut faire qui va
leur permet de rentrer dans le marché
même c'est celle pour les aider depuis
dix ans la montée des prix a été
fulgurante
une maison unifamiliale moyenne du grand
vancouver coûte plus d'un million six
cent mille dollars
c'est presque quatre fois plus élevé que
dans le grand montréal
dans les villes de vancouver il n'y a
qu'une demi douzaine de maisons
unifamiliales
à moins d'un million de dollars comme
cette aubaine de l'est de la ville à 869
mille dollars
et si vous êtes plus fortunés cette
demeure à retaper est à vous pour la
rondelette somme de 2 millions cent
quarante mille dollars le revenu
familial médian à vancouver est à peine
plus élevé que celui de montréal
alors comment expliquer cette hausse
vertigineuse les bas taux d'intérêt
la spéculation et l'investissement
étranger ont tous contribué à alimenter
la bulle immobilière
mais un autre facteur important est venu
gonfler les prix le blanchiment d'argent
tout d'un coup il ya des acheteurs qui
sont prêts à payer des prix plus gras
que ce que le marché normalement
permettrait parce qu ils ne se servent
de rein
à l'ombre des tours du centre ville se
trouve le d'anthony sadc milliers
toxicomanes le trafic la drogue comme le
fentanyl il fait des centaines de
victimes à chaque année personnes
meurent chaque année dans notre province
on sait le crime organisé qui alimentent
cette dépendance à la drogue
gary résultat beaucoup d'argent comptant
doit intégrer le système financier pour
être blanchi selon un rapport d'experts
mandatés par la province jusqu'à cinq
milliards de dollars par année sont
blanchis dans le marché immobilier de la
colombie-britannique provoquant une
hausse du prix des maisons de 5% à
l'échelle provinciale
pis le german était le sous commissaire
de la grc en colombie-britannique
il a effectué deux études sur le
blanchiment d'argent
à la demande du gouvernement provincial
d'abord on blanchit l'argent sale grâce
un commerce et beaucoup de transactions
se font en argent comptant les casinos
sont parfaits pour ça voici des images
stupéfiantes captée dans des casinos de
la colombie-britannique des joueurs
venus de chine échange des dizaines de
milliers voire des centaines de milliers
de dollars en argent comptant contre des
jetons de casino
on y voit des liasses de billets tenus
par des élastiques comme le font les
trafiquants de drogue
une part des fonds blanchis dans les
casinos se retrouve dans l'immobilier
vous ne verrez pas de sacs d'argent
comptant chez les courtiers immobiliers
des fonds qui aboutissent dans
l'immobilier ont déjà été placées dans
le système financier
mais selon peter james des sommes encore
plus importantes proviennent directement
de l'étranger par virement électronique
sans qu'on pût sans vérifier l'origine
ces fonds sont envoyés dans les comptes
bancaires d'avocats canadien et
contrairement aux banquiers et aux
agents immobiliers les avocats ne sont
pas tenus de signaler des transactions
douteuses aux autorités fédérales en
raison du secret professionnel
c'est l'un un trou béant dans le système
de surveillance canadien
l'argent déposé dans les comptes en
fiducie des avocats est invisible pour
les policiers beaucoup d'argent sale
pourrait ainsi entrer au pays ne sais
quoi car on est incapable de voir où ces
fonds entre dans le système financier
mais cet argent va directement dans
l'immobilier en 2010 est un avocat de
west vancouver a été suspendu par le
barreau de la colombie britannique
il a utilisé son compte en fidéicommis
pour transférer au nom de clients près
de 26 millions de dollars provenant de
paradis fiscaux sans se renseigner
adéquatement sur les circonstances la
transaction et sur l'origine des fonds
nos avocats et d'autres actions que même
vulnérables ce genre de transaction
mais la majorité d'entre eux une âme un
sac très bien qu'il ya des questions qui
ne doit proposer à nos clients et puis
bon ils peuvent continuer à procéder
comme si rien n'était
de plus l'utilisation de prête-noms pour
dissimuler les véritables propriétaires
est courante en colombie britannique
selon l'analyse de peter james plus de
33000 demeure ont été achetés par des
personnes qui se disent chômeurs
étudiants ou femme au foyer
ces gens ne peuvent pas acheter une
maison
mais c'est peu probable car il s'agit
surtout de maisons de grande valeur
ce sont probablement des prête-noms sont
déjà en colombie-britannique la grc
avait une équipe d'une vingtaine de
personnes consacrées à la lutte au
blanchiment d'argent
mais cette équipe a été démantelé en
[Musique]
c'est un problème pour combattre ces
crimes complexe il faut des équipes
intégrées comme on avait avant des gens
formés en comptabilité ou en droit ll
qui sont aussi des enquêteurs qualifier
quel est le risque pour lui peu près pas
c'est un secret de polichinelle
il ya eu très peu de dunkerque qui sont
faites sont menées et raccords encore -
dunkerque sont menées avec succès pour
s'attaquer au problème le gouvernement a
constitué une commission d' enquête sur
le blanchiment d'argent et dès le mois
de juin
un registre révélant les propriétaires
réels des biens immobiliers sera
instauré une première au canada
mais lorsque les activités du crime
organisé sont exposés au grand jour les
criminels changent leurs méthodes ou des
places leurs activités de blanchiment
vers d'autres provinces au mort des ce
qui rend vancouver attrayante pour le
blanchiment d'argent se retrouve aussi à
montréal les gens québec devrait
considérer ça comme signal dallas
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ces
reportages et 7 spécial immobilier d'
enquête au nom de toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là revenez nous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]
je